okay now I'm very pleased to introduce
our speaker today Martha
rasle um in just a little information
about her talk tonight prediction of the
next event is important for
organizations to improve and optimize
their system process to achieve
organizational goals existing predictive
models are limited since they use
Discovery algorithms
that might not be able to conserve the
sequences of events as reported in the
log Discovery algorithms alter the
sequence of events in two ways either
the algorithms generate an additional
sequence of events not found in event
logs or remove the order of events since
prediction relies on these processed
algorithms the prediction model can
suffer and produce underperforming
results models that do not use Discovery
algorithms such as deep learning models
ignore completely the sequence of
events
oopsies to overcome these limitations we
propose a new algorithm called ax DP
adjacency Matrix deep learning
prediction Model A XDP predicts the next
event of a process using graph Theory
techniques specifically adjacency
matrices and predicts the power of deep
learning models axp has a major
advantage in that the sequence of events
is conserved and resulting in better
prediction of the next event when
testing axp on eight publicly available
data sets a axp outperforms what we
believe to be the most recent and best
predictive models that exists for the
prediction of the next event for six of
the eight data sets Okay and then on to
our speaker Martha
rosin thank you thank you what a
pleasure what a beautiful day right cold
so let me see the Boer works or would I
have to tell you about the
slides okay that's fine so my name is
Martha I am a very interesting person
because not only do I get involved and
dive in into mathematics uh
engineering all of these machine
learning deep learning I'm also
businesswoman so I run several
businesses one of them being my favorite
I'm the CEO wos palet it's a palette
company I'm also an author of a book
series called business Diva along with
that I'm a business consultant and I'm
still finishing my doctorate at UIC and
this is one of my Publications and it
was a theoretical piece that was
accepted by the iple E access which is a
big deal so I'm excited to share this
work with all of you so let's go to the
next
slide all right so what is the problem
so you know there's a lot of prediction
models out there but my focus was really
on analyzing process mining models so
what do these do the essence of a
process mining is that you take data in
form of event log I will show you
shortly how an event log looks so you
can visualize but basically you're
giving this data set an event log form
and then you create a graphical
representation these graphical
representations have names called
petrinet and reachability graphs so you
can just think in graph Theory the nodes
and the edges so these nodes usually
represent the
activities the events and then the edges
represent some connection between those
events okay so just so you get an idea
so what is the issue existing issue with
process Mining and the modeling methods
is that they tend to
overgeneralize so there's traces so they
don't preserve they don't conserve the
information and that's why there was a
need for me to develop something that's
able to conserve the information of
events and also keeping in in regards
the time of data when data happened
because at the end of the day if you
think about it how do we learn past by
looking at the past right and in order
to look at the past we need to look at
those different time stamps so that is a
power of process mining um another top
of type of modeling is deep learning
models the thing with deep learning
models if you know this is that they use
activation functions and they're so
complex inside of these activation
functions it's hard to explain it it's
not like linear uh uh like what am I
talking multiple linear regression or
linear regression you have the slope and
you can easily explain it multiple
linear regression you have a a bunch of
variables and you can easily explain
those right in deep learning you can't
really much explain so the essence is
here what I'm trying to do is develop a
model that takes event and conserves
those events for every Trace so let's go
to the next
slide so this is some of the existing
work that's used to for prediction the
goal here is to predict the next event
when you're thinking the next event this
can be an anything I mean just think
about automation when you're designing a
vehicle how to predict when there's
going to be the next flaw when the
machine is not going to work if a
company cost them a million dollar let's
say a few thousand dollars and this
happens a lot you want to avoid that
right that's why prediction in that
scenario is important in a medical
setting let's say you're looking at
cardiac durest patients you want to
reduce the number of patients that die
due to cardiac duress so you would like
to predict when that is going to happen
to avoid that it doesn't always have to
be a negative outcome but this is the
Ence of what we mean with predicting the
next event so these are some of the
existing work the best out there I mean
I read tons of
Publications so you have long you have L
lstm long short-term memory
uh deep learning models they use one hot
en coding and then transform these
activities these event locks into
vectors then you have um rrn neuron
networks you have embeddings and lstms
and the best one so these are different
methods okay they use deep learning
models the best one existing so far was
ma this last one right here and they Ed
a multi-input approach basically what
they do is they take everything they
take an event log they take the resource
they take the frequency they take the
activity they take everything into a
deep learning model and they use a
coding function before they put it into
these this deep learning model for
prediction so point is that there's
already these existing models you can
look them up they are in the paper if
you look up the paper and you can read
them deeply yourself but this is what I
did let's go to the next
slide so there's these eight data sets
all of these papers use these eight data
sets they're commonly used as a
benchmark to see how models perform when
you're comparing with different modeling
methods I mean for example B12 this is
an application process so when you're
applying it's an application process you
have all these data sets it's eight of
them so these are the number of traces
and events and the number of activities
and I will show you what this means
let's go to the next
slide okay so this is an event log this
is this is what I was talking about and
this is how process mining works it
takes data in this form so you have an
event like a patient that's what it's
called a trace patient one is one Trace
patient two refers to a trace two and
notice that there's a timestamp
Associated for every description in this
case being the activity so instead of
calling it description I should really
have called that event so for patient
one which is my Trace one there is a Tim
stamp associated with that activity so
to put it in context text if you go to a
doctor you check in that is you are
Trace one you represent Trace one as
that patient so your first activity is
you register then you're going into the
room then they do your vitals that's
another event then another event will be
discharge okay so we got that idea so
this is what an event logs and this is
the form of the data and this is how it
looks in context all right let's go to
the next
slide so what was my goal my goal was to
create a reust an accurate framework for
predicting the next event in a system I
focus mainly on medical data but this
also works in business because that's my
goal at some point is to use it in my
business and in any existing
organizations you can think non
for-profit you can think profit you can
think anything even in how they run this
organization right now we have probably
10 people here how what is the
probability that the next uh date the
next month will be another 10
or when would be 20 you can use this if
you collect data in event lock form all
right so what is the approach my
Approach I did a lot of research and I
also come I I did mathematics and one of
the things that came up was graph Theory
you see how they use adjacency Matrix
graph Theory it was a combination of
graph Theory and linear algebra so I
combined the idea of adjacency matrix to
uh to plot these not to plot but to grab
to to set these events so I cons serve
the the sequence of events and I'll show
you how I did that so why adjacency
Matrix there's no added or lost
information like we saw in process
mining with these Petry Nets enrich
ability graphs adjacency Matrix have
been used in the past like their igen
values maximum igen values these
features they still don't know why they
work okay but these features have been
important in determining cognitive
disabilities and making um understanding
complex problems in the medical field
that is where where this idea even came
from why adjacency Matrix it just shown
medically that it helps a lot the
different components of adjacency Matrix
I'm like let me give it a try and it
worked this came from this idea let's go
to the next
slide all right so what are the
advantages think about this the
advantage here is conserving the
sequence of events for every Trace if
you think patient I am not removing any
of the events nor I'm adding them nor
I'm changing it I am conserving them by
using this adjacency Matrix so let's see
how the algorithm
works okay so phase one you're given an
event lock here represented by this L
and you have a trace you remember how
you saw that Trace okay so every Trace
you have different events so what we're
doing first is creating a tup of those
events so you have a b CDE e events okay
just think about that AB b c d so I
would take A and B and I'll create a
tupo then I have the next event B and C
then I'll create that tupo then I have C
and D I'll create that tupo so that's
the first thing that's referring to my
first consecutive events then I'm going
to create the second uh consecutive
events which which is a and c and then c
and e okay so now I'm going to create a
third consecutive event I'm just doing
first and second but I also do the same
with third a and then D and then D and
you you get the idea of what I mean so
then I create these different tupos for
first second and third consecutive event
and I do that for every
trace and every Trace has their events
do you want me to go back to just show
this or is anyone lost
here yeah let's let's go back to that
event
log here let me put it from here okay so
let's assume this event registr A B C D
E F G H okay I'm going to rephrase them
so one first consecutive tupo will be
these two second consecutive will be
this registration and check vitals and
then the third one will be registration
and and physician
care you got
that no I will put them together so A
and
B it's but different terminology I just
combined them
here no it's it won't be a tupo in
Python for me it just refers that I put
them together I con tve them is that the
word pair values there you go pair
values I make pair
values so here I'm forming a list I'm
making a list a
b okay I just call it t here because I'm
making
two no no I'm not using that so no
okay basically what I'm doing is listing
them I didn't bring the source codes but
I would have showed
you okay but I can share the source code
when you got when I'm done I can show it
to
you I use
python no it's not related to Python
language no it's related to math
language okay let's go but at least you
got the idea what I mean with these
consecutive events and second
consecutive and third consecutive events
I just want you to visualize it what I
mean okay so for every Trace I do this
so let's go to the next one so that's
step one for every trace this is how I
combined these different consecutive
events okay so now I have a AC c a d so
I create an a Jency list and from the
adjacency list I create my adjacency
matrices so now I have an adjacency
Matrix for first consecutive
events then I have an adjacency Matrix
for the second consecutive events and
then I have a cons a jcy matrix for the
third consecutive events so how does
that work so if we were to put all these
events in adjacency Matrix then you have
a b c d here on the on The Columns and
on the rows a b c d so if you go A to B
and I will assign you a one and if you
don't have a node or you don't there's
not existing Tuple then you're a zero if
you are a and then b a a ba and I will
sign sign a two
okay it'll be nice if I had a board to
write these things but do you get me
okay so we create this adjacency Matrix
let's go to the next
one all right
so for every Trace now we're going to do
this so now we have our first Matrix
we're just going to reshape it because
we need to I'm going to the ejected is
to is to use this as an input for the
Deep learning model for the neon Network
okay so for first consecutive events
they are M number of traces and N number
of events so it'll be M byn squared
Matrix here now we reshape the first
Matrix so what is going on is M
represents the number of traces remember
that would be the number of patients and
N is a number of events so we're going
to square that because the Matrix was an
N byn okay all right so that's my first
entry for my axp algorithm let's go to
the next one so now for the other ones
for the second and third consecutive
events what I'm going to do is I'm going
to calculate the igen value and I'm
going to take the maximum igen value as
inputs so I'll take igen Max 2 and um
Ian Max 3 input two and input three and
this keeps some of the information of
the relationship of these events in the
second and third order all right let's
go to the next
one okay so now we're going to calculate
the frequency of every event for every
Trace so how many A's happen how many
registrations happened I mean in medical
in reality it will be only one
registration but how many events for
every patient the frequency of them
happen so that'll be my input for into
this deep learning model all right let's
go to the next
slide so this is the general framework
you have your data in event log form you
remember how that looked I take my
reshaped first
consecutive uh adjacency Matrix that we
reshaped in to an M byn squar then I
take the max igen value representing the
second and third consecutive events and
then I take the frequency of those
events and then I feed them into a deep
learning model so they go into this
neuro Network that's a whole different
thing that I can spend a whole day
explaining and then we predict the next
event we can go to the next slide
now so this were the results note that
we comp compared with eight different
not eight I compared in this paper with
six different models but for the
reference of this picture I just
compared directly with ma which I said
that was the best related to all the
other research so just for your point of
reference for like quicker and one easy
graph I only compare here directly with
MAA but in the actual paper I compared
with six other different predictive
models so what did we find out is that
axp works we still I mean I don't think
anyone will be able to answer this right
now why does the I maxic and aan value
work no one will really be able to
answer that yet but it works why does
the adjacency Matrix works I can answer
that because we're conserving the
information makes sense if you are being
fed information and being taught Petr
process mining sometimes can and it's
like the telephone thing it can give you
not the whole story but adjacency matri
concerns the sequence of events so it
gives you everything so as if you're
learning you have the whole information
now it depends on your interpretation
but if you only get a snap of the
information or information that's not
the entirety of it then you're not going
to really learn or interpret the
correctness you get me in this case
you're not going to make the correct
prediction so that is why The adjacency
Matrix is stronger than all of these
lstms RNN convolution neuron networks
because of the essence of the conserva
of the sequence of events okay let's go
to the next slide let me see how I'm
doing in time okay so these were the
results for six of the data sets
remember we have eight different
publicly available data sets the Au
score was the highest compared to all
the Baseline models
so six out of eight for 19 16 and 13 so
these are the the names that I use in
the citations 19 is ma 16 is n lsdm and
13 that's
tax 13 is lsdm and 16
was it was a deep learning
model have a higher Au score than axp
for this particular data set I still
don't know why and that is what I want
to figure out why didn't my model
perform good on on
bp12 complete and then axp has the
lowest compared to all models on B17
offer uh but in general we can make an
argument that axp is the better model
because 75% of the time it outperforms
the state of the art Baseline models I
will love more data because I keep
testing it but it did work too on a
medical data that I use for paralytic
Alo I already published one paper but I
can publish this but they didn't let me
using my method they want me to create a
new method so let's do
it they're like that's too easy Martha
that's
experimental so I need to create a new
theoretical work all right let's go to
the next one so what are the limitations
and maybe someone can figure this out if
you want an open
problem one of the biggest problems in
literature I don't think anyone has
really figured it out is when you have
data and it's not
balanced so for example if you have dead
and alive patients you mostly have less
dead patients than alive right hopefully
that's just an example and in a company
you have less errors than you have
successful cars being built but in that
class in
Balance how how do you deal with that
there's a lot of different works that
have been developed but there's no like
okay this is the formula the magic
formula so that's something in the
future I will actually like to keep
working on how to deal with class
inbalance and I know I'm not 100% sure
but I'm sure that in these two data sets
that I explained before B12 W complete
and B17 that probably explains why the
model didn't perform that well because
there's probably a lot of class
imbalance because in some of these datas
you were dealing with 12 different
classes
so that means like 12 different events
that you could have predicted a b c d f
g h i do you me instead of zero to
one so imagine having a class imbalance
in zero to one and also having a huge
class imbalance in 12 different events
one event can have just one occurrence
but for example the 12th event can have
20,000 occurrences do you get me where
there there's a problem there okay
so I would like to test other neuro
Networks for this paper I just did relu
I don't know if you heard relu is the
commonly used activation function in
your networks I actually developed one
and I hope that paper
publishes no one can know yet but maybe
implementing different activation
functions that we can develop so that's
something I'm working on how to improve
existing activation functions so they
can work for this class imbalance
issue I don't know we'll get there um
another thing is convolution NE networks
I'll probably start there before I
create one cuz convolution NE n there's
already existing python code for it um
let me see I'm forgetting
anything no that's said any questions
for
me oh this is a conclusion I kicked
their butts
basically
yes
um the reason they use Au versus let's
say accuracy score they have their Ops
and they have their POS uh they goods
and their bads but Au has been used for
imbalanced classes best so if you're
dealing with imbalanced classes then go
with an au score and of course because
I'm comparing with existing literature I
need to use a common Baseline so those
are the main two reasons if I'm talking
about accuracy and they're talking about
Au score like we're not talking about
the same thing it's those two reasons
but Au score I will go with au score
over accuracy especially with dealing
with such a broad range of data with
class IM
balance
what you can do for those instances is
add a weight
within python I I didn't do it for these
experiments but there is a code that you
can add in a wait when you are
predicting within the neuro Network you
can wait one
class
for I didn't try it here but would it it
probably will but I had to be more
strategic and the thing is that now this
will become a whole different paper it
will become a paper of like how do you
stratify how you put weight on class
imbalance hey and maybe that soles a
class imbalance if there's a system or
an algorithm for stratifying how to add
weights oh my God what if this is a
start this is
crazy I know I'm going to go back to my
house in the plane because I'm going to
a plane right
now but for you and this is what I
noticed in Time series there is one flaw
with time series it only looks at
time there is other factors
involved so maybe creating the time
series and adding more variables like a
market index or something I don't know
because I'm not an expert in that
area
so I don't know the answer why it really
worked
the why I used it I used it because I I
my research was on the basis of medical
field so in my in my department we do
research on predicting different
diseases different like cardiac durat
diabetes Pi so I dived into uh adjacency
Matrix and then I found a lot of
Publications that use maximan igen value
to determine for example the different
patterns in our
brain like if you look into this Ian max
value in medical predictions you would
be like oh my God this is incredible so
when I saw that I'm like there is
something behind the igen max
value we can
h
and and it forms and it is a
characteristic of that adjacency Matrix
per se right because it's a linear
function of these other components that
make that adjacency Matrix so that's a
smaller set of the big
Matrix so this is another reason I also
used it because I can use the big Matrix
imagine I have 19 events then you're 19
by 19 so it's 19 squared that is huge
but now if I take the igen max value is
one component rather than this
large yes there you go and next time I'm
going to answer exactly like
that yes I use
python
no let me see let me see what time I'm
at H I can't connect my computer here
right there is a port for
uh for Samsung I have a
Samsung yes send it on LinkedIn and I'll
go through my
computer hey we should do we should
torture the people online well you're
not going to see The Source codes
because you didn't show up in person I'm
just
kidding
right I I'll be quick because I gotta
run this is python I gotta show it to
you
you can see the
beauty I'm just going to use mine oh
it's free you don't there's no password
oh
perfect
recording in progress
friend